the only way that you're going to be
able to push past the mountain of
obstacles that is going to try to stop
you is to have maniacal focus to know
exactly what you want
you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
what's that belief nation it's evident
my one word is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to make
a difference now I started to believe
life series two once and we talked about
different topics outside the world of
just hardcore business and sort of help
you live your best believe life today
we're gonna look at how to start your
day the right way also if you want to
know what Tony Robbins Eric Thomas and
Mel Robbins have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
video that is thirty Seconds to five
minutes long for free every single day
to help you build your confidence check
out the link in the description below
all of us have kind of an identity for
ourselves a way of defining ourselves
and human beings don't usually stray
from that so if you consider yourself to
be a conservative person or a shy person
I know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
the way you use your body and it's all
consistent with the fact that human
beings our strongest drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves I have a ritual where even if
you and my closest friend I have
boundaries hmm so just because it's my
company it doesn't mean I can take calls
all day right I have boundaries so you
can't call me in a certain time why I'm
working you know I talk a lot about
being honest with yourself about what
you want and if you're somebody that's
watching this and you have no clue what
you want I'm gonna say that's total
[ __ ] I think you've probably decided
that either you can't have it because
you don't think you're smart enough or
good enough or worthy enough or maybe
you think you're too old
or you've told yourself that you can't
make a living doing it
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have maniacal focus with Tom bill
you this is critical whatever it is that
you're going to do in your life if you
have any interest in doing something
extraordinary if you have any interest
in performing better than other people
if you have any interest in doing
something that will be remembered this
is the takeaway for you pick one thing
and do it with force and determination
the only way that you're going to be
able to push past the mountain of
obstacles that is going to try to stop
you is to have maniacal focus to know
exactly what you want to have clarity of
purpose to have a crystal clear vision
in your mind of what you're trying to
accomplish something that you could tell
anybody in a single sentence when you
have that and you stare at it all day
and you think about exactly how you're
gonna make it happen and you tie your
identity to it then you've got a chance
because then my friends when that
obstacle comes before you you will
muster the force that you need to
destroy that obstacle and this is where
this kind of aggressive language and
thinking is going to help you because
they will not go quietly and that's the
problem that a lot of good gentle
beautiful Souls have is when the time
comes they don't muster the force that's
required to get what they want and I
know you know like I do somebody who's a
beautiful person who's a good human
being that we wish good things for but
sometimes bad things happen because they
don't stand up for themselves and as
jaco willing said most of us aren't
defeated in one decisive battle were
defeated one tiny seemingly
insignificant surrender at
that ships away at who we should really
be that's how we lose rule number two
get honest with yourself with Mel
Robbins I've always wanted a six-pack
and I don't have it and I don't know and
I've never had it and when I I finally
stopped complaining about it when I got
honest about what it was gonna require
I'm dead serious dead serious about this
at my you know at forty nine with my
affinity for alcohol and my love of
carbs and my distaste for exercise I
have a small problem on my hands if I
want a six-pack so if you were to go
forward right and think okay well if a
year from now I had a six-pack what
would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that and then you can
stop beating yourself up for this never
intend on doing what I realized is I can
spend four minutes a day in a hotel room
or in my bedroom doing planks and my
arms look great and everybody else will
think the rest of my body is in shape it
works like a charm so you might want to
get honest with yourself I can study
doing this the ability to do this do you
really because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay if I'm
able to put $1,000 a month against my
debt I'm able to make X amount of
dollars a month I'm able to put X amount
of dollars in savings what do I need to
be doing a year from now to make that
happen and what are those habits that
are there a year from now that I don't
have right now and then roll yourself
back to this moment just like I
explained with exercise do I actually
not want to have a Manhattan tonight
nope did I want to go to the gym today
nope
did I am I willing to not eat what I eat
for nope
and my Willa I did my 4 minutes my arms
are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting at any
moment you time travel forward a year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now and you decide
am I willing to do this now if I'm
willing then five four three two one
through all the excuses that are gonna
be there when you're trying to override
your operating system that's how you do
it or you have the reality check like I
had which is ocean but I just like the
beach I don't intend on changing so why
don't we get this off the plate and
let's focus on the things that I am
actually committed to rule number three
choose to be great with David Goggins my
favorite cream is swim yeah you know
what saying I mean Muffy we had little
athletes in my damn family you know and
I was a kid who kind of got the kind of
bad genes you know out all these little
sickly issues all these allergic - I was
a little sickly kid it's funny how when
people hear my story now they want to
put a title on me like I'm superhuman
yeah like you had some special
capability and I love it because
basically it makes you feel better but I
put a title on me right you can do -
that's right and so base Joyce
yes choice yeah it's a horrible choice
it's man it's a hard choice it's a lot
of suffering involved so for me to get
this dart line through that start line
journey I realize I'm capable mm-hmm so
what happens to this whole process is
the change of the mind mm-hmm it's a
change of the guard mm-hmm someone once
owned my brain I never owned it no I
never had no I had no control you out
your outsourced yes right everybody had
it it was my dad's fault
it was a kids that called me [ __ ]
fault my mom wasn't home fault my
shouldn't be stepdads fault little kid
that gave it about buzz fault my life
was everybody had a piece of my brain
yeah and through this journey of
suffering and the suffering I put it in
because I started finding myself yeah I
started on the ticket back for me this
part of my brain is mine now I'm so
puzzling back this piece of my brain and
through that I grew confidence in this
process I went from David Goggins
started forming a guy named Goggins
mm-hmm I had to really invent I realize
had to reinvent a whole nother human
being right within myself because who I
am wasn't gonna make it this is not this
guy's not gonna cut it so I think I did
be a guy who can take any kind of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually I had had the people who
visualize everybody that called me
[ __ ] you have to be in a room of
people like this hmm I had to make up
these things in my mind at least I had
to overcome and and I started callus in
my mind do it through a process and it
debate start with working out the start
was working I started with doing like if
it started raining outside for instance
my mind was said that man I'm gonna run
mm-hmm if it was three o'clock in the
morning start raining outside my mind
said you gotta go get up and go really
you have to because I was fighting this
other person so you essentially tried to
do everything you didn't want to do
that's all that was period not
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
interest every single thing so we're we
find comfort you know that's where I
started getting scared now when I
started saying oh it's raining I'm not
going out there no you cannot say that
you cannot do that you you have got to
do this the other so whatever my brain
thought I did the opposite mm-hmm
wherever the comfort wasn't with the
opposite direction in over a period of
time
boy it calluses - mm-hmm out of your
mind
you start to really develop a whole
nother being and rule number four the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is wanted badly enough with Eric
Thomas when I wrote my dreams and my
goals down look when I wrote my dreams
and my goals down take a look at it guys
when you want to succeed as bad as you
want to breathe I'm telling y'all I'm
telling y'all the four-year degree the
Masters the PhD when I went after I'm
showing you right where I graduated from
that's why I'm standing here cuz I need
y'all to see it I need y'all to see
where I watched across the stage this is
where I did it y'all I want it as bad as
I wanted to breathe I got up in the
morning and I walked them down give me
before I get out of here you ain't got
him on you you ain't got a had a
and in life I'm leaving you with this
you ain't gotta had the best hand in
life you ain't got to start with the
two-parent background
you ain't got to start with wealth you
ain't got to start with your parents
graduated it's not the hand that you
dealt you got rich kids who own drugs
you got rich kids who committed suicide
you got rich kids who who don't know
their purpose in life it's not the hand
that you were dealt baby it's how you
play on hand it's your boy et said if it
was easy to do everybody would do it I'm
not saying it's gonna be easy but you
have what it takes if you listen it to
make it happen so do me a favor get up
get out and go get something
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Tony Robbins on how to give energy
to think you're really gonna join but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions we are
moving from not just watch another video
but to actually taking action in your
life and in your business so answer
these questions by yourself talk about
them with a friend or leave the answers
down in the comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
improve your focus on question number
two what honest truth do you need to
recognize about yourself and question
number three what are you going to
choose to be great at thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
everything in my world is based on
coming up with the outcome that will
serve and then going at it but most the
time your approach going at it doesn't
work no one else knows that but you know
you can see it doesn't work so it's
constantly changing your approach until
you can get where you want to go and I
enter an audience and I'm gonna give a
talk of any sort now I do a huge amount
homework in advance I prepare as he is
there but then when I stand up here I
wouldn't be sitting like this I'm
scanning constantly who I'm looking for
the people think it's [ __ ] I'm gonna
have the people who got dragged there
I'm not looking for the people clapping
for me you know those people will always
be there and there's some people clap
even if you're terrible so you don't
want to other people see you make you
feel good I'm looking for who isn't
there so that I can reach them so I can
show them that there's something real
here because you know most people don't
know who I am they'd see you know ten
thousand people jumping in a stadium and
they go it's just a big motivational
pumpup I've never been a motivator it's
never open I don't want I've been about
I think motivation is useful is like a
warm bath you should probably take a
bath or a shower every day but you need
more than that you need strategy and but
what I really believe is the energy most
of us grew up and right now most of you
are learning and the traditional style
you did leave when you're in school you
were trained to go to your seats and be
silent and be polite and nice but the
world we live in today isn't like that
the world today if somebody sits down
and waits for someone tell them what to
do they're in trouble so my approach is
constantly stimulating and seeing what's
real getting people to be raw and
getting to truth you know it's corny as
it is the truth sets us free and we all
can find our own truth as long as we put
ourselves in environment where we don't
tolerate anything less than that
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video